qui peut assurer que cette communauté vit bien sur les eaux de Lagos.
Voici Francis Kéré.
Il travaille dans le pays d'où il vient :
le Burkina Faso.
Kéré et son équipe ont conçu des projets en utilisant techniques traditionnelles.
Kéré et son équipe en travaillant dans les communautés
ont développé des prototypes pour des écoles
tels que la communauté entière,
ainsi que pour tous les projets dans les villages de ce pays,
se rassemble pour construire.
Les enfants apportent des cailloux pour les fondations,
les femmes apportent de l'eau pour la production des briques,
et tout le monde travaille ensemble pour battre les sols d'argile.
Travaillant avec la communauté,
Kéré et son équipe ont créé des projets plus fonctionnels
avec un éclairage et une ventilation adéquates.
Ce sont des projets adaptés pour ce contexte
et qui sont vraiment beaux.
Pendant les 7 années dernières,
j'ai travaillé comme architecte au sein du groupe MASS.
C'est une agence de design née au Rwanda.
Nous avons travaillé dans plusieurs pays d'Afrique,
en nous concentrant sur ce modèle plus équitable et viable
d'architecture pratique.
Le Malawi est un de ces pays.
Un pays avec des beaux paysages isolés,
avec des grandes montagnes et des vallées fertiles.
Mais avec un des taux les plus élevés de mortalité maternelle dans le monde.
Une femme enceinte au Malawi soit accouche chez elle,
soit elle doit marcher longuement jusqu'à la clinique la plus proche.
Une mère sur trente-six meurt pendant l'accouchement.
Au Malawi, avec notre équipe du groupe MASS,
on a créé à Kasangu un foyer pré-accouchement.
C'est un endroit où les femmes vont six semaines avant la date prévue.
Ici, elles reçoivent les soins prénatals
et elles apprennent nutrition et planning familial.
En même temps, elles forment une communauté
avec d'autres futures parturientes et leurs familles.
La conception de ce foyer pré-accouchement
adopte les modèles indigènes des villages au Malawi
et se réalise en utilisant techniques et matériaux simples.
Les blocs de terre qu'on a utilisés étaient fabriqués à partir de notre sol.
Cela réduit l'empreinte carbone de ce bâtiment,
mais avant tout,
cela offre un espace sûr et digne pour ces futures mamans.
Ces exemples montrent que l'architecture et le design
ont le pouvoir d'aborder des problèmes complexes.
Mais plus important,
on peut élaborer un modèle de solutions efficaces
pour nos communautés.
Pourtant, ces 3 exemples ne suffisent pas.
Même 300 exemples ne suffiraient pas.
On a besoin d'une communauté entière d'architectes et designers africains
qui fournisse encore des milliers d'exemples.
En mai de cette année,
on a organisé un symposium sur l'architecture africaine, à Kigali,
et on a invité beaucoup de designers africains éminents
et d'éducateurs en architecture travaillant partout dans le continent.
Nous avions un point en commun.
Nous étions tous allés à l'école à l'étranger
et hors d'Afrique.
Cela doit changer.
Si nous voulons développer des solutions qui conviennent à l'Afrique,
plutôt que transformer Kigali en Beijing,
ou Lagos en Shenzen,
on a besoin d'une communauté
qui promeuve la confiance et l'assurance de la prochaine génération
d'architectes et designers africains.
(Applaudissements)
En septembre,
on a créé le African Design Centre
afin de former cette communauté.
On a fait entrer 11 membres venant de tout le continent.
C'est un programme de bourse de 20 mois en design et construction.
On y apprend à relever des défis importants,
comme urbanisme et changement du climat,
comme Kunlé avait fait.
Ils travaillent avec les gens
pour développer des méthodes de construction innovatrices,
comme Kéré et son équipe avaient fait.
Ils comprennent l'impact sanitaire des meilleures infrastructures,
comme nous du groupe MASS avons mené des recherches à ce sujet
depuis plusieurs années.
Le point culminant du programme est le projet qu'ils ont conçu et finalisé.
C'est l'école primaire Ruhehe, leur projet.
Ils se sont plongés dans la communauté pour en comprendre les difficultés,
et aussi découvrir des opportunités,
comme utiliser un mur fait de pierre volcanique local
pour faire du campus un espace de jeu et d'apprentissage actif.
Ils ont évalué les conditions environnementales
et développé un système de toit qui exploite la lumière du jour
et améliore les performances acoustiques.
La construction de l'école de Ruhehe commencera cette année.
(Applaudissements)
Au cours des prochains mois,
les membres du African Design Centre travaillerons main dans la main
avec la communauté de Ruhehe pour construire l'école.
Quand on leur a demandé
ce qu'ils veulent faire après la bourse,
Tshepo, d'Afrique du Sud, a dit
qu'il voudrait introduire cette façon de construire dans son pays :
il prévoit d'exercer en pratique privée à Johannesburg.
Zani veut élargir les possibilités des femmes de devenir ingénieurs.
Avant de rejoindre l'African Design Centre,
elle a contribué à Nairobi
à lancer une organisation pour réduire l'écart de genre dans l'ingénierie,
et elle espère étendre le mouvement à toute l'Afrique
et au monde entier.
Moses, de Soudan du Sud,
le pays le plus nouveau du monde,
veut ouvrir la première école polytechnique
qui apprendrait aux gens à construire avec des matériaux locaux.
Moses a dû être déterminé pour devenir architecte.
La guerre civile a perturbé sa formation à plusieurs reprises.
En même temps que il posait sa candidature au African Design Centre,
on pouvait entendre les tirs au cours de son entrevue téléphonique.
Mais même au milieu de la guerre,
Moses n'a pas renoncé à l'idée
que l'architecture puisse être un pont pour réunir les communautés.
Par la conviction de ce gars, nous devrions comprendre que
une architecture remarquable peut changer les choses
ainsi que la façon de bâtir notre avenir.
L'expansion sans précédent en Afrique ne peut pas être ignorée.
Imaginez ses villes dans le futur,
non plus comme des vastes bidonvilles,
mais comme les lieux les plus durables
et socialement inclusifs de la planète.
Cela est faisable.
Nous possédons le talent pour que cela devienne réalité.
Mais le parcours pour préparer ce talent en vue de la tâche assignée,
tout comme mon propre parcours,
c'est trop long.
Pour la prochaine génération de leaders créatifs africains,
on doit réduire et rationaliser ce chemin.
Mais le plus important,
je ne le soulignerai jamais assez,
on doit renforcer leur confiance
et leur permettre de développer des solutions spécifiquement africaines,
mais d'inspiration sur le plan mondial.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)